[Musica]
ciao ciao a tutti grazie sono onorata di
essere qui oggi e di parlare dopo degli
speaker così di rilievo come le tre
storie che ho appena ascoltato
spero di essere all'altezza
io sono francesca gottardi
sono un friulana l'ipo milano e oggi
però vi parlo da dar es salaam in
tanzania
ho 36 anni e come appunto avete appena
sentito solo la co founder e ceo di
andrea che è una piccola star tacco di
moda etnica che pulisce europa e africa
sono molto felice di essere qui oggi a
parlare il mio primo che dexter e trovo
molto appropriato che si tratti di un
the next che parla di rigenerazione e
che si tiene in una città come prato che
è storicamente associato ai tessuti e
appunto la loro rigenerazione
oggi nel 2021 se in una frase dico le
parole tessuti e rigenerazione non posso
fare a meno di pensare a quella che
ormai è diventata la parola chiave di
questo nuovo decennio ovvero
sostenibilità
c'è un argomento di cui so qualcosa
l'annuncio che appena pubblicato il mio
primo re appoggi sostenibilità come vi
racconterò tra poco è però quello che è
interessante notare è che ad oggi il il
tema della sostenibilità viene
normalmente associato a un macro
argomento che quello dell'ambiente con
tutte le tematiche derivate di impatto
ambientale economia circolare ciclo di
cui tutti abbiamo sentito parlare
insomma ampiamente in questi anni è
invece pochissimi sanno che la
sostenibilità si collega anche un
secondo aspetto ben distinto che è
quello della cosiddetta sostenibilità
etica ovvero delle persone io vengo dal
mondo della moda e oggi sono qui per
raccontarvi un po meglio il legame che
c'è tra le persone nella moda e
soprattutto di come sia possibile
rigenerarlo che quello che sto provando
a fare yoko nel delle a
cambiare insomma il il collegamento che
c'è tra i vestiti chi li fa e chi li
indossa
quattro anni fa quasi 4 choeur mai mi
sono licenziato dal lavoro a tempo
indeterminato in una grande azienda di
moda a milano per creare hendel ea noi
siamo una società benefit e questo
significa che comunque cerchiamo di
mettere le persone al centro di tutto
quello che facciamo le nostre collezioni
sono disegnate milano e vengono
realizzate qui in tanzania da un gruppo
di parte tanzaniane cercando di essere
trasparenti inclusi di vite sostenibili
in tutto quello che facciamo
inoltre noi dedichiamo una parte dei
ricavati delle vendite sono sul sito in
delle appunto it à la sponsorizzazione e
la collaborazione con le università e le
scuole della tanzania in modo da poter
portare competenze risorse in questo
paese e aiutare la nascita e poi mano a
mano la crescita di un industria della
moda locale che oggi qui ancora un po
manca meglio perché vi sto raccontando
di andrea perché la storia di andrea
quello che noi facciamo qui in tanzania
oggi e rigenerazione appunto è una forte
cambiamento della prospettiva con cui si
può fare un capo d'abbigliamento come ad
esempio una donna e quello che facciamo
noi è innanzitutto cercare di garantire
uno stipendio in linea diciamo con il
costo della vita alla sarta che ha
realizzato questa donna lo stipendio che
sia in grado di garantirle una vita
dignitosa e di mantenere la sua famiglia
ma non solo quello che facciamo è anche
offrire la possibilità di lavorare da
casa in modo da poter integrare diciamo
il suo lavoro con la gestione dei
bambini e della famiglia se lo richiede
le offriamo corsi di formazione ogni
anno in modo che possa continuare a
crescere come professionista e
guadagnare sempre di più le offriamo
un'assicurazione sanitaria i pasti
gratuiti trasporti gratuiti e in
generale a cerchiamo di stabilire un
dialogo con ognuna delle sarte che
lavora con noi in modo che siano
protagoniste del loro lavoro
questo lo facciamo perché crediamo
fortemente in una rigenerazione
possibile del mondo dell'amore come
vengono realizzati i capi
d'abbigliamento che tutti i giorni
indossiamo e crediamo in quello che
appunto viene detto facci vedere
l'impatto zero nella possibilità che ha
anche la moda di avere un impatto
positivo sulle persone che lavorano
lungo la filiera io vi ho raccontato un
po la storia tendere a che è appunto una
storia di rigenerazione della moda del
modo di farlo da il modo di fare moda
però la serie tenere anche fortemente un
affare di rigenerazione personale mia e
credo che un po tutta la mia vita lo sia
stato quindi mi prendo un attimo due
minuti per raccontarvi chi sono e da
dove vengo e poi torno a parlare di moda
rigenerazione
la prima cosa che dovete sapere di me è
che sono un'archeologa e ho visto il
primo film di indiana jones quando avevo
7 anni e da lì ho deciso che volevo
essere marche mola e coltissima mi sono
laureata cittadine archeologia pisa
quindi meno lontano da prato dove si
tiene questa fedex e poi come tantissimi
italiani laureati nel mondo della della
cultura numeri culturale delle lettere
ho lavorato gratis per quasi due anni
punto nel settore culturale salvo poi
fare un primissimo salto nel vuoto
quindi una prima rigenerazione di me
stessa e del mio percorso di quella che
era stata dire ha voluto rime fino ad
allora per iscrivermi al master in
marketing e comunicazione in bocconi che
è stata un'esperienza molto interessante
molto sfidante che mi ha permesso poi di
venire assunta il primo lavoro
retribuito della mia vita da un'agenzia
web che ha deciso di scommettere su
l'archeologa che aveva studiato
marketing ma che non aveva nemmeno un
account twitter all'epoca i lavori in
agenzia mi ha permesso di mettermi alla
prova rigenerarmi ancora una volta
imparare tutto
mondo dei social media e man mano
mettere quello che stavo imparando a
disposizione di un mondo un po più ampio
noi questo un po risuona con quello che
diceva venire prima
superare il comfort zone e chiedersi
anche che cosa nel mio superare al
console sony può essere d'aiuto agli
altri e quindi all'epoca avevo creato
questo progetto sveglia museo che
serviva a mettere in collegamento musei
stranieri in usa italiani per aiutare i
musei italiani e crescere e migliorare
nella loro politica xenon line sto
parlando del 2012 2013 quando
effettivamente il severo molto critica e
il mio progetto e un lato
inaspettatamente bene al punto che ne ha
parlato anche il ministro dei beni
culturali e appunto che mi sono
ritrovato a fare un secondo enorme salto
nel vuoto nella mia vita e quindi
lasciare il giuridico lavoro retribuito
che avesse avuto fino ad allora prendere
a lavorare gratis nuovamente nella
cultura
questa volta però in america in uno dei
miti più grandi del mondo che lo
smithsonian institution è effettivamente
ho potuto realizzare il sogno della
bambina di 7 anni perché questa che
vedete qui effettivamente la scelta
originale dei film di jobs alla faccia
di chi dice che i sogni non si
realizzano dopo aver lavorato allo
smithsonian sono forate l'italia sono
stata consulente per il mondo dei musei
per un po e poi diciamo che raggiunti i
30 anni alla ricerca del della
cosiddetta stabilità economica tanto
decantata ho fatto il nuovo santi nel
vuoto e sono passata al lato oscuro
della forza
accettando un lavoro come social media
manager appunto in una grande azienda di
moda la stessa che vi raccontano prima
che ho lasciato poi quasi quattro anni
fa per creare quella che invece è la mia
piccola azienda di moda tra di rame per
spam a contendere a dove sono oggi
oggi sono sì o di due start up una
milano una destra viaggio tra i due
continenti fiume erano i tre mesi
gestice continui che è circa di 30
persone tra il tar e la tanzania
ho vinto il premio gaetano marzotto 20
30 social impact e ho pianto per
mezz'ora quando sto appunto di averlo
vinto e ho pubblicato appunto il primo
record di sostenibilità come vi dicevo
all'inizio ogni giorno imparano le cose
ogni giorno affrontino le sfide in reati
mentre a clienti investitori è sempre
alla ricerca di nuovi investitori è
fondamentalmente diventa qualcosa di
diverso e di
sfidante in modo diverso ogni giorno
quindi eccoci qua perché vi ho
raccontato di ende leva perché vi
racconta di me io sono una grande fan
dei the text e mi piace moltissimo il
fatto che da ogni ted chi lo guarda
possa portarsi a casa qualcosa quindi
credo che sia importante
raccontarvi quello che poi ho imparato
in questi 11 anni che vanno diciamo
dalla mia laurea in archeologia
attraverso tutti questi tanti nel vuoto
fino dove sono oggi qui a dar es salaam
a parlarvi di rigenerazione di moda la
prima cosa che ho imparato è sicuramente
che è molto difficile cambiare qualcosa
se sei tu il primo a voler cambiare
sostanzialmente niente cambia se non
chiami tu per primo se non sei pronto a
mettersi in discussione e ea campi e
mettere discussione tutta la tua vita
nel nome di questo cambiamento
quello che ho fatto io conto è una
rigenerazione un cambiamento almeno
l'obiettivo è quello di rigenerare un po
in modo di fare moda ma questa
rigenerazione partita da una necessità
molto umane molto personale mia di
cambiare me stessa di riconoscerlo in
quello che facevo
nel mondo della moda a milano ha
cominciato a farmi molto stretto e non
sopportavo questo senso costante di
ansia come se stessimo salvando delle
vite umane invece di semplicemente far
accessori
e un certo punto mi sono detta ma se
davvero trovassimo un modo per cui la
moda può salvare le vite anche se non
penso
ma nell'impatto comunque positivo sulla
ri per le persone che contribuiscono
alla sua creazione no quindi davvero
prendere a tutti gli effetti si e messa
in un processo di cambiamento del
sistema moda ma questo processo partito
da un'esigenza molto via disdette armi
la mattina e di dare un senso alla mia
vita che alla spira dello stipendio che
stanno guadagnando no qui li può di
nuovo quello ricollegarmi gli interventi
prima che c'è anche daniele nel
raggiungere un livello oltre di
rigenerazione di cambiamento di cui
davvero qua ti chiedi come tu puoi
diventare una leva per cambiare il mondo
intorno a te però sono un party letto
inviare te stesso in un bacio lontano
la seconda cosa che ho imparato è che è
molto difficile cambiare restando cerni
il viaggio è una dimensione che persona
to race stelline da perché ci è nuovo e
diverso e l'altro e soprattutto ci
costringe a imparare ogni volta delle
cose nuove di noi stessi e rende reale
mi sono messa letteralmente in viaggio
all'inizio del 2017 andando il bambi
acqua in tanzania a fare ricerche e
abbastanza letteralmente da allora non
sono mai fermata come vi dicevo ogni tre
mesi circa sto viaggiando tra i due
continenti sicuramente è stancante però
mi sento di momenti di consigliare a
chiunque li poiché ci sta guardando e
che abbia voglia di dare un cambiamento
la solita di cominciare con comprare un
biglietto aereo e partiremo inserimenti
da sola da solo per cambiare un po le
prospettive la terza cosa che ho
imparato è che è molto difficile
cambiare senza contaminazione e questo è
forse ricollega al tema del viaggio nel
senso che comunque così come è possibile
cambiare stando da fermi chloe
[Musica]
anche cambiare senza scambiare idee con
nessun altro quello che facciamo con
rende le ha appunto creare un ponte tra
l'italia e l'africa non lo dicevo
all'inizio questo conte mi piace pensare
che nei nostri clienti sono portano
addosso
comunque ogni giorno nei vestiti che
acquistano da noi ed è molto bello
pensare che questo fonte che loro
indossano in realtà il fatto di infiniti
aneddoti finiti momenti buffi ma anche
drammatici che sono stati affrontati in
questi anni da tweet in un italiano un
africano che hanno imparato del tempo a
lavorare insieme crescere insieme
il fatto di mettere a confronto due
culture e così tanto diverse ma
veramente credetemi tanto diverse potrei
parlare per ore di share e che sono
successe pool in tanzania è un caso che
comunque a noi ovviamente ha create
delle difficoltà ma anche un'incredibile
occasione di crescita umana e nel totale
del cambiamento che ne stiamo portando
nel mondo della moda lo ha reso più
forte su questo tema delle persone mi
ricollego per raccontarvi la quarta cosa
che ho imparato 0 che è molto difficile
cambiare da soli
io non credo assolutamente a chi dice
che non vuole condividere un'idea per
paura di essere copiato o criticato e
credo invece fermamente che la rete oggi
sia l'unica dimensione è possibile per
la sopravvivenza sia di un'impresa come
andrea ma anche di noi come esseri umani
e ad oggi senza le persone che io ho
incontrato in questi anni che se sono
umano mano giunte team di andrea in
italia come in africa io farei solo una
sognatrice con un'idea c'era invece che
abbiamo tutti bisogno di professionisti
con cui collaborare una rete di
sicurezza che ci accorga quando siamo
disperati amici con cui parlare e anche
assolutamente nemici che ci costringono
a rivedere e migliorare costantemente la
nostra idea
e questo un po si collega al punto 5 di
che cosa ho imparato ovvero che molto
difficile cambiare senza paura senza
dubbi o penso sbagliare mai e questo
perché credetemi quasi quattro anni di
tacco nel dl ea sono stati infiniti i
momenti in cui mi sono detta ma chi me
l'ha fatto fare ancora oggi non nascondo
che ci sono giorni in cui penso se le
cose dovessero andare male io posso
sempre cercare settimana come succede di
avere leggere nel mondo della moda e ho
sbagliato infinite cose in questi
quattro anni però la cosa importante da
sapere è che sbagliare è l'unico modo
che abbiamo per imparare più c'era il
corso di laurea in cio e
[Musica]
imprenditorialità diventiamo start upper
cosiddetti un giorno alla volta un
errore alla volta una nuova lezione
imparata alla volta e soprattutto anche
mettere in dubbio tutto non è negativo
ma è un segnale che ci sentiamo
veramente tantissimo quello che stiamo
facendo e siamo abbastanza coinvolti da
volerci anche mettere discussione come
imprenditori comitati come se stessimo
il percorso diciamo nel mondo delle
startup e quello che poi appunto voler
cambiare rigenerare qualcosa che è
sempre stato fatto in un certo modo e un
percorso lungo e faticoso ed è
normalissimo avere dei momenti no e
questo mi porta dirvi che un'altra cosa
che ho imparato della penultima giuro
ferisce acuto oggi è che è molto
difficile restare nel cambiamento e con
questo intendo accettare il cambiamento
richiede moltissimo tempo
lui è difficile soprattutto per qualcuno
come me che non è nato o dotato di
grande pazienza e credetemi che dopo
quattro anni in ende reati nel frattempo
appunto come vedete da questa foto è
diventata due aziende e ha presentato
infinite difficoltà a nuovi scenari
nuove concitazione i nuovi team nuovi
avvocati commercialisti quant'altro cioè
ogni tre mesi andrea una nuova una nuova
società una nuova realtà restare in
questo cambiamento restare
focalizzati conservare l'energia trovare
un equilibrio è molto difficile e come
dico spessissimo scherzando gli anni in
una start up si contano milioni di
camper o un male almeno sette se lo
youtube e si sentono tutti però anche in
questo punto va accettato va trovato
l'equilibrio e il
compito kiss cercando di cambiare le
cose anche i ciottoli appunto imparare
sta bene giumento questo fatto della
facoltà del cambiamento è guastata
all'ultima cosa che li ricordi che
appunto era più importante cogliere il
cambiamento è reale solo se condiviso e
e questo ero nel senso che come abbiamo
ascoltato anche dalle storie precedenti
ovviamente noi che cerchiamo di cambiare
le cose cosiddetti stata per me piace di
più parlare degli imprenditori i
sognatori siamo quelli che questo
cambiamento stanno cercando di
realizzarlo in prima persona sono quelli
che abbiamo lasciato i nostri lavori
sono cambiate le nostre vite piccoli
lotti sciolte che lottano contro i
mulini a vento
e va bene così e continueremo a farlo
però la rigenerazione che noi stiamo
cercando di portare nello specifico mio
del mondo della moda potrebbe essere
reale solo se davvero viene sposata da
tutti voi attraverso le scelte che fate
ogni giorno come consumatori
potete scegliere una donna alla volta un
paio di scarpe alla volta di iniziare a
far vedere le idee prima di acquistare
qualcosa in questo caso specifico il
capo d'abbigliamento
chiedervi come è stato fatto è stato
fatto da chi è stato fatto quanto è
stata pagata quella persona e scegliere
così di diventare a vostra volta che il
loft potrebbe essere detto un
facilitatore del cambiamento no io sono
un agents of change un agente di
cambiamento ma senza l'aiuto di una
community peste fa che capisce quello
che sta facendo e che vi aiuta a farlo e
farlo sempre meglio sarà molto difficile
per me è molto più lento e faticoso
cambiare le cose
quindi detto tutto questo
il mio intervento ricordando appunto il
claim di rendere aetr involved quindi
come 18 3 assurti a
non arrendersi
quindi nel mio caso specifica non
smettere non può sognare in grande
questo noi lo continueremo a fare queste
sono le ragazze e ragazzi del nostro
team in tanzania quello che vi tutto è
magari oggi quel potevi a casa un po un
messaggio di cambiamento possibile e di
anziani ci aiutiamo sussulti a cambiare
le cose insieme una donna alla volta
grazie